joined by professor stephen paris the
medical director of nhs
england and by dr susan hopkins who is
the chief medical advisor to public
health england
and to nhs test and trace i've got quite
a lot of news to bring you up to speed
on and right at the start
i wanted to tell you where we are with
our vaccine program
i'm so proud of the team who've now
vaccinated
9.2 million people across the uk
that includes 931
204 vaccinations just this weekend
and to put that into context that's one
in every
60 adults in the whole united kingdom
vaccinated in one single weekend it's a
mammoth effort i know just how much
these jabs mean to people
and i'm so grateful for all the messages
that we get
all the pictures that i'm sent of people
being vaccinated
it fills me with pride that so many
people
are doing so much to help
for this rollout to happen so smoothly
and i want to say thanks to you all
getting vaccinated is an emotional
moment for so many people
and that's because it is about
protecting those who are most vulnerable
to covid we've now vaccinated almost
nine in ten of all over 80s
in the uk and now as of today
we've vaccinated over half of
all people in their 70s and i'm
delighted
that i can tell you that we have visited
every eligible
care home with older residents in
england
and offered vaccinations to all of their
residents
and staff this has been an incredible
example
of health and social care working
together
working side by side to protect people
who are
in the most need as professor martin
green the chief executive of care
england said today
this is a wonderful achievement and one
that is testament to the hard work
of care home staff and our colleagues in
the nhs
and local authorities and i want to
thank every single person who's helped
us get this far
i also want to let you know some good
news on vaccine supply
today we've ordered another 40 million
vaccine doses from valniva
as we've have all along we've invested
early
and at risk before we know for sure if
it'll come good
because from the start we've taken a no
regrets
attitude to backing vaccines
we've tried to leave nothing on the
table if this gets
regulatory approval the valniva vaccine
like many others will be made right here
in the uk
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine is made
in oxford and staffordshire and wrexham
the novovax vaccine is being
manufactured
in t-side and if approved this valniva
vaccine
will be manufactured in livingston in
scotland
we didn't start this pandemic with a
large scale
onshore vaccine manufacturing capability
so we're building one all across the
united kingdom
and the vaccine program just goes to
show
how important it is the whole uk
working as one together
we now have over 400 million doses of
vaccines on order
this is obviously more than the uk
population needs
and my attitude has always been we
protect
every uk citizen as fast as we can
and at the same time we're generous
around the world
i want to say this to our international
partners
of course i'm delighted about how well
this is going
at home but i believe fundamentally
that the vaccine rollout is a global
effort
one of the many reasons that i'm so
happy with the astrazeneca contract
is that it not just gives us a strong
supply here
but because it is the only vaccine
currently being deployed
that is available to the whole world at
cost and because it's logistically
straightforward
it can be practically deployed to the
poorest parts of the world too
so we will protect uk supply
and we'll play our part to ensure the
whole world
can get the jab another area where we're
helping
around the world is in spotting new
variants
and our global leadership in genomic
sequencing has helped us to spot new
variants
here in the uk and quickly to alert the
rest of the world
but there are other countries that don't
have the capacity
that they need last week we offered our
capacity and expertise to other nations
through our new variant assessment
platform
because a mutation in one part of the
world
is a threat to people everywhere for
example
our south african colleagues spotted a
new variant through their high quality
genomic sequencing
and rightly notified the world as we did
with the variant that we discovered here
in the uk
we've now identified 105 cases of this
variant here
11 of those cases don't appear to have
any links to international travel
there's currently no evidence to suggest
this variant is any more severe
but we need to come down on it hard and
we will
we've already made sure that all these
cases are isolating
and that we've done enhanced contact
tracing
of all of their close contacts we're
surging extra testing
into the areas where this variant has
been found and sequencing
every single positive case working with
local authorities
we're going door to door to test people
in the local area these cases have been
identified in the following postcodes
in w7 n17
cr4 ws2
me15 en 10
gu21 and pr9
if you live in one of these postcodes
where we're sending in enhanced testing
then it is imperative
that you stay at home and that you get a
test
even if you don't have symptoms
this is so important so that we can
break the chains of the transmission
of this new variant
and we've got to bring this virus to
heal
so there's lots of good news
but this is a stark reminder that the
fight against this virus isn't over yet
every day we're protecting more people
and getting ourselves
one step closer to normal life but this
is no time to let things slip
so let's all of us do what we must to
get this virus
under control